this is a production of cornell
university
good day everybody hello my name is
miles schwartzak
i'm a graduate student here at the
department of horticulture i work with
the urban horticultural institute and
i'm going to talk to you today
about a couple things first i'm going to
talk about the the concept of soil
health
and how this is a an important way that
we're starting to think about soils
in this day and age and i'm also going
to talk about some of the research that
i've been conducting while i've been
here at cornell
particularly pertaining to soil
remediation
using a technique we call the scoop and
dump method
so i'm going to start off here like i
said talking about soil health and when
we think about soil health what we're
thinking about
is the integration of multiple aspects
of soil science
and the three main areas that we're
talking about are the physical
the biological and the chemical
a lot of kind of traditionally in soil
testing
we've mostly focused on just the
chemical aspects
of soils which are very important
aspects
but there's kind of a bigger picture and
more to be told with the story
so the concept of soil health is is
finding the the most important
indicators
of your soil that are responsive to
management
so it can be changed by a practitioner
and also correlate well
with plant growth so here at cornell
we developed the soil health test out of
the crop and soil science department
and what this test does is it's a set of
standards
like i just described that when
integrated together
kind of gives you a holistic picture of
your soils
and this test is just like any other
soil test that you could
send a sample into and have results sent
back to you
but different from maybe strictly a
biological or chemical test
we cover a a bunch of different aspects
so when we talk about physical we're
mostly referring to is aggregate
stability
water holding capacity bulk density
texture and resistance or compaction
is a synonym when we're talking about
biological
mostly what we're thinking about is the
soil microorganisms now
this is going to cover organic matter
active carbon
which is just a fraction of total
organic matter
as well as soil respiration and protein
and also when we're looking at chemicals
we're going to be primarily looking at
ph and as well as our macro and
micronutrients
so as i go through this talk today i'm
going to introduce
these kind of concepts specifically and
then
when we talk about my results i'm going
to give a little more detail
about what these actually mean for the
practitioner
so when we're talking about soil health
we're talking about looking at specific
indicators
within specific
aspects of our soil so when we're
talking about the
physical aspects we're mainly talking
about aggregates
so the actual particles that
conglomerate together in your soils
and so size and distribution as well as
stability how easy they break apart
we're talking about porosity how easy
how much air is in your soil and how
much space is between your aggregates
and your
in your structure we're talking about
bulk density
which specifically refers to weight by
volume
and is a very good indicator for
compaction which can oftentimes be
a large inhibiting factor in
our soils or at least our abilities to
be able to
grow landscape plants directly in them
resistance as well which is a measure
another measure of compaction
which we can use a penetrometer a very
easy field tool to use
to get a a quick sense of what our
compaction looks like
and as well as water holding capacity
how much water is in the soil that is
available for your plants
and water infiltratability so how
quickly water can move into your soil
when we move on to the soil biological
factors mostly what we're talking about
is the microorganisms that we find in
our soil
and these play very a very important
role and have been an area of research
that has been gaining
more traction and more focus in recent
history
but a lot of what the biological factors
tend to focus on
is the ability for microorganisms to
mediate
soil nutrients turning over in the soil
as well as contribute them contributing
to
organic matter also the fixation of
nitrogen
is a common benefit we see from soil
biological
factors as well as detoxification of
pollutants
and the maintenance of soil structure
and as we're kind of thinking about soil
biology
uh the kind of mantra that i like to go
with or that you tend to hear frequently
is that what we're thinking about uh
specifically with nutrients
is feeding the soil uh not necessarily
feeding the plants specifically
and we'll get into this a little bit
more as we continue our talk today
and then the third major area is soil
chemical
and soil chemical refers uh to the
specific
micro and macro nutrients that are
required for plants to be able to grow
and
thrive in a given environment as well as
the specific ph which is also going to
be a limiting factor for what kind of
plants you can
use in that soil and then cation
exchange capacity
which specifically refers to the ability
for soil to hold on
to nutrients and then allow them to be
plant available
so that was a quick summary of what soil
health is and the general concepts that
go with it
and i'm going to move now into talking a
little bit about urban soils and
remediation
and if you're unfamiliar with the
concept of urban soils what we're
talking about when we're talking about
urban soils
are soils that are are non-agricultural
not necessarily naturally forming or not
naturally forming
and in one way or another are influenced
by
human impacts and development
so um
a definition that i like to use is
non-agricultural
man-made surface layer more than 50
centimeters thick
that has been produced by a mixing
filling
or contamination of land service in
urban and suburban areas
so when we talk about urban soils what
this can really refer to
is it could refer to parks it could
refer to botanic gardens it could refer
to
right of ways on highways
could be talking about urban like city
cores or even suburban
just like people's yards so soils that
are in one way or another
are influenced by human activity
and the reason why we define urban soils
in the first place
is because there's a number of set
characteristics that we tend to find
in our urban soil systems and these
characteristics typically
tend to have adverse effects on the
landscape plants that we wish to put in
those landscapes
so what we tend to find in an urban
system is high soil bulk density
decreases in organic matter poor
structure
high ph low water holding capacity
a decrease in aggregate stability
inadequate depth for for roots to be
able to
proliferate in the soil and as well as a
decrease in microbial biomass
and activity
so here at cornell we were trying to
think of ways of of how to kind of
uh proactively deal with with urban
soils and some of the challenges that we
tend to see with them
so uh in the urban horticultural
institute
in unibastic's lab we focused on
developing this technique
known as the scoop and dump technique of
soil remediation
and the practices is relatively
straightforward
what you do is you come in with compost
into a compacted
and disturbed urban soil site and you
apply that compost at a rate of six to
eight inches
on the top of the soil surface and then
you come in with either a backhoe
or mini excavator or you can even do it
with shovels and what you do is you you
physically use your backhoe to fracture
and
scoop down to the soil reaching into the
subsoil
you lift it up that soil shake it and
drop it
and what this does is it creates a
heterogeneous mixture of compost and
soil
and after that point you can either
rototill it or just iron rake it over to
create a smooth
planting surface and then you apply
mulch and what you have after this
at this point is a planting bed that is
now
you can directly put plants into
mostly we've used this with shrubs and
tree species
and this is just a few pictures of what
it kind of looks like you can you do
this technique either by
using a backhoe or by using if you have
a lot of
help you can do it by shovels but it's
accessible and you can use it to either
create large planting beds or very small
planting beds if you want to just put
one tree in or just a few shrubs
or if you want to renovate a large area
and on the cornell campus we've been
doing the scoop and dump practice for
the last 14 years now as a part of
neenah basics
creating the urban eden woody plant id
and landscape establishment class every
year
the class will create a new garden on
campus
and when they design this garden and
then eventually install it they've been
using the scoop and damp
technique and we've used this technique
in
in a various number of places this is a
picture of outside of a mann library
when we were doing construction a few
years ago
and you can see that the the landing
area right in front of the building
here's another angle of that of what a
construction landscape looked like and
this is what the landscape looks like
today where we've come in we've used the
scoop and dump technique
to remediate the soil and now it is a a
place where it went from highly
compacted
and impacted from construction to a
place where having our landscape plants
thrive and survive
so we wanted to kind of look at the
scoop and dump technique and learn a few
things about it
we wanted to find how changes in soil
quality
based on soil health had changed in
response to doing the scoop and dump
technique
and we also wanted to look at this to
see how since we had 12 years worth of
gardens or 14 years at this point
we were able to see over time also how
changes were made
so we selected three sites
where this technique had been applied
and three sites directly adjacent to it
this way we could do a control type
experiment where we had plants growing
or so we had soils that had been
developed by the scoop and dump
technique
and then we had areas that were close by
that had
received similar impacts but
had not gone through the same
remediation
so we went to these sites and we took
soil cores
we took three of them they were about
this size and we took these cores and we
extracted samples directly from our
scoop and dump soils and then at equal
depth we also took them
in our unamended and we went just below
our mulch level because as i mentioned
when you do the scoop and dump technique
you add mulch every year as you would in
any kind of
landscape bed establishment and we
selected our unamended or control soils
at the same depth as we found our scoop
and dump soils so i'm going to go
through the results
that we found of our study and as i
discussed these i'm also going to
discuss
some of the soil quality indicators and
what they mean
so we get a sense of not just what
happened but giving a broader picture of
soil health
so the first thing i'm going to talk
about is aggregate stability
and what we're talking about when we're
referring to aggregate stability
is essentially the soil aggregates these
large particles
that have conglomerated together and
their ability
to resist destruction and the
destruction of forces that we apply on
them
or water there's two ways you can look
at this you can either look at this by
flooding how much the aggregates break
apart when inundated with water
or you can look at it as we do in the
soil health lab
using a rain infiltrometer here which
simulates a very heavy rainstorm event
and essentially the the more stable your
aggregates the less they break apart
the better that is for your soil
structure and
just generally uh creating a kind of
more agreeable environments for
our plant to put our plants directly
into
so when we looked at the scoop and dump
versus our controlled soils what we
found is that
our scuba dump soils had uh 72
aggregate stability and if you compare
this to our unamended
we see that our unamended is at about 34
and so just by doing the scoop and dump
technique coming in and incorporating
organic matter and physically fracturing
the soil
and mulching over their site we saw that
we had almost double
the amount of aggregate stability
next we have organic matter and what
we're talking about when we're talking
about organic matter
is it's primarily carbon that is derived
from a living source
so whether this be plant or animal
residues or microorganisms that we're
finding in the in the soil
it's a little more involved than that
but as a basic sense that's we're
referring to and organic matter is a
very important component of our soils
i think most people kind of know that
the it tends to be the more organic
matter you have in the soils
uh it it improves structure and it
certainly is beneficial for
cation exchange capacity therefore the
ability for soil to hold on to nutrients
so in a functioning ecosystem where we
want our plants to
thrive and survive organic matter is a
very important indicator to look at
and on average when we look across these
sites what we see is that our scoop and
dump soils
we have 8.43 organic matter compared to
our unamended
that is at 3.23
so almost three times the organic matter
after doing this incorporation
which makes sense since we're adding
compost we're adding a lot of organic
matter
but it's good to see this
next there's active carbon and this is
kind of a
newer test that some people may not be
as familiar with
but what we're talking about when we
talk about active carbon is essentially
it's uh
the fraction of your organic matter that
is available for soil microorganisms
to consume and to use as a food source
so active carbon is a biological
indicator
and it really is
a little different than our total
organic matter because that refers to
all of the all of the organic matter we
find active carbon is just a fraction of
it
and is this food source for our soil
microorganisms which play mediating
roles
in our nutrient turnovers and what
we see when we looked at active carbon
is that
our active carbon we are up around
1022 parts per million compare this to
our unamended
at 361 and so almost
we have more than three times the amount
of active carbon in our scoop and dump
soils
moving over to water holding capacity
water holding capacity specifically
refers to the amount of water that is
being held
in your soil that is available to plants
so on one end of the extreme
you have field capacity which is the
amount of water that's held in the soil
when you've had a large rain event and
just due to gravity alone the water is
drained out of it the amount of water
that is held in the soil
after that draining event is known as
field capacity
and on the other end of the spectrum you
have what's known as
permanent wilting point and permanent
wilting point refers to the point
where the amount of water in the soil is
no longer available to plants
so plants cannot pull it up from their
roots
and therefore the plant will start to
have a drought response at this point so
water holding capacity is between
these two extremes so this is very
important as you'd imagine
for thinking about irrigation and also
thinking about
just general maintenance of plants in
the landscape
and what we see with available water
holding capacity is that
in our scoop and dump we ended up with
0.23
well you compare this to our unamended
which is 0.15
and these differences may not look as
large as some of our other indicators
but statistically this is quite
significant and we see that our our
scuba dump soils do hold significantly
more
water so the next indicator i'm going to
talk about
is potentially mineralizable nitrogen
and
what this indicator refers to
specifically is the conversion
of nitrogen for an organic form
into an inorganic form so going from
plant unavailable
to plant available and what i put have
up here on picture of this slide is the
full
nitrogen cycle and i'm not going to go
into full detail about this
but this is just kind of one one
component of it potentially
mineralizable nitrogen is another
biological indicator since this is
mediated by soil microorganisms
and also since nitrogen is such an
important
element for or nutrient for
plants to use an important one to look
at and when we looked at potentially
mineralizable nitrogen
in our scoop and dump compared to our
unamended soils what we found
is that we had almost 10 times the
amount of potentially immoralizable
nitrogen
compared to or unamended so 27.53 parts
per million compared to
3.11 in our unamended
next we looked at resistance using a
pentrometer
pentrometer for people who aren't
familiar with it is
is this instrument right here it's
pretty straightforward it has a
pressure gauge on one side and a
measuring bar in the middle
and what you do is you take this and you
can push it into your soil
at a consistent rate and measure at what
point
your soils reach a pressure of 300
psi or higher and the significance of
300 psi
is that that is the kind of point in
your soils
where roots can no longer proliferate
in a compacted soil so you know if
you're below that threshold
that your roots are going to grow fine
if you're above it then you're going to
you have a compaction issue and you need
to address it one way or another
there are some limitations to using this
instrument it's best to use it directly
a short time after it rains especially
if you're going to be doing a lot of
different sites because soil moisture
can make
a difference in how you read it but it's
a great way to just get a quick estimate
of what the compaction looks like in
your soil and why we talk about it in
terms of soil health
and so when we looked at our scoop and
dump compared to our unamended what we
found is that in our scoop and dump we
could go down to 9.74 inches
before reading reaching our root
limiting
psi compared to our unamended which was
at 3.44 inches
so we had three times the rooting volume
or depth available to us that plants
could therefore
grow explore and use
next we looked at bulk density and as i
i
discussed before what bulk density is is
a measure
of weight by volume and this is another
indicator that's important to consider
when looking specifically at compaction
it is a little bit more telling
than using the resistance measure or the
pentrometer measure
and pretty straightforward to take but
we use these rings typically
to measure bulk density and
we'll hammer these into the soil get
them kind of flush so we know
how much volumes in here specifically
dry them out and then weigh that
and what we can tell the bulk density
just like we can tell with resistance
is that we know depending on texture
that
once you get above a specific bulk
density you start to
have trouble having roots grow
and proliferate in your soil so
in sands it's 1.75 grams per centimeter
cubed compared to silts and clay which
is around 1.4
and these numbers may not mean a lot
right now but as i discussed bulk
density several times throughout this
talk
there's going to be it's going to start
to make more sense
and so what we found in our scoop and
dump soils is that
we were at 0.89 grams per centimeter
cubed
which is well below that 1.4 threshold
so regardless of texture
we saw that by doing this process that
we were able to reduce our bulk density
and create a medium
where roots are going to have a much
easier time growing compare this to our
unamended
which is up at 1.47
and depending on texture you're kind of
just getting to that root
root limiting range so after we did our
first kind of study where we looked at
scuba dump soils in the compare and
contrast
setting we also wanted to look at how
did these soils change
over time so we selected
a cross section of 12 years
and we selected six sites out of those
that represented
that time frame and when we looked at
this in chrono sequence
what we found out is that over time our
bulk density decreased
we found that our potentially
mineralizable nitrogen
our nitrogen that is being converted
from in
organic to an inorganic form also
significantly increased over time
as well as our active carbon the portion
of our
of our total organic matter that is
available for micro
organisms to use as a food source
and it was really exciting to see this
because um when we did our first study
what we could see
is that yes by going in and doing the
scoop and dump practice we improved we
approved improved soil quality almost
immediately
and that was the first piece of data
what we saw when we looked at this over
time
is that by going in and doing this once
and then mulching every year
that there is an increased benefit that
keeps on
going after we've used this technique
active carbon
as well as potentially mineralizable
nitrogen are both biological indicators
so it gives us a good clue into what's
going on with the micro
the microbes in our soil and their
ability to
to mediate soil health and as well as
this bulk density which
continues to create an environment where
after we've established these plants
they're going to have a lot easier time
growing
so this is all very exciting to see and
what we wanted to do next was say all
right we've seen
that we've improved our soil quality and
that's a great thing but we also want to
see how plants respond
to these changes in soil quality
so we set up a soil container study
where we went out again to our scoop and
dump sites
and our in our unamended sites and we
took large cores pvc cores
that we hammered into the ground and
pulled out and
we were then able to take these soils
bring them into a growth chamber
and grow plants in them specifically to
see
how the plants responded to this
improved environment
and we were able to look at a number of
different factors
but first what we did when we took these
we used a ficus benjamina
which is known as a tropical street tree
we did this because we were running this
experiment in the winter but it is
oftentimes
a plant you do find in the urban
environment in
tropical and subtropical regions and so
the first things we looked at
after growing and establishing these
ficus benjamina
was how just what were the gross
plant growth response so we see
here that in our scoop and dump soils
compared to our unamended
vikings that were gone in there had
significantly more leaf area leaf area
was the first indicator that we looked
at
up at 933
centimeters squared compared to our
unamended which was at
578 centimeters squared
so significantly more leaf area was put
on
by the plants growing just in the scoop
and dump soil
when we destructively harvested and
extracted the roots and the shoots from
the plants what we found is that
we had significantly more dry weight of
roots for plants growing in our scoop
and dump soil compared to our unamended
and again these these differences do not
look
giant but statistically they are
significantly different
as well as the dry weights of shoots we
also had significantly more
shoot growth compared in our in our
scoop and dump soils compared to our
unamended
so again like in our last study we also
looked at bulk density
this measure of weight by volume and
what we found again
is that our scoop and dump soils are
were at this
0.97 range which is again
well below that 1.4 threshold compared
to our unamended soils which are up
in the 1.68 on average range
and we're starting to see limitations in
the soil based on that
so what we did is we did a linear
regression where we looked at
bulk density by our dry weight of shoots
so shoots referring to everything from
the soil line up
so leaves and any woody biomass
that was developed and what we see is a
very strong relationship here of
in the blue we have our scoop and dump
we have
more shoots on the axis here as well as
higher bulk densities so what we see is
a very clear relationship where we're
actually looking at
um the lower our bulk density is
correlating very strongly with
more dry weights of shoots and we can
see in our unamended soil
that this line right here is our 1.4
threshold we start seeing root limiting
bulk densities
they're all kind of clustered down and
when we look
at the dry weight of roots as well we
see
a very similar pattern of our reduced
bulk density correlating with
more root growth
as well as our leaf area we see the same
pattern yet again
where we have strong correlations with
reductions in bulk density
and increases in leaf area so when we
did this
uh destructive harvest after we had um
pulled the plants out of the soils
containers that they had been growing in
uh there was a few observations that
were
they were made that weren't so easy to
necessarily quantify and one of the big
things that we saw was just
was just where the roots were exploring
in these containers
and how much more you know
biomass they're putting on so this is a
pretty clear picture of our scoop and
dump roots you can see
a lot more a much larger root system
developing here compared to our
unamended
which is just not nearly not nearly as
dense
and what was interesting when we looked
specifically
at where the roots were in the container
is that
in our unamended soils
plants that were growing in our soils
that had not been remediated
that had this higher bulk density what
we would typically see is that
where we planted the ficus in the
container there would be roots that were
growing
right where we stuck the plug in and
then oftentimes what the roots would do
is they'd grow up from that plug
across the top of the container and then
down the sides
and so what the roots were actually
doing in this in this scenario was they
were not exploring the majority of the
soil volume in these unamended soils
but finding a way to kind of follow the
path of least resistance
and looking for an area where they could
grow
and escape so it's a very similar
pattern that you see here where you kind
of they came down
you kind of came down the middle where
you planted the plug and then they'd
escape off to the side
if you compare this to what we see in
our scoop and dump soils
the roots growing in our scoop and dump
soils had the ability to
really grow throughout the full amount
of the soil volume
they'd explore between those aggregates
and those different air space
and they the the volume they wouldn't do
the same
escaping pattern they would just grow
throughout the whole container
and even when you tried to break the
soils apart in your unamended soils
when you start to break the roots and
the soil apart the soil would just kind
of fall away
in our scoop and dump soils you'd be you
really have to work really hard to
to actually free the soil from the roots
to be able to get this so this was all
exciting to see and kind of in summary
i talked about early on that some of the
issues that we see in in urban soils
and characterization and by coming in
and doing the scoop and dump process
we've been able to improve the majority
of them
pretty much everything except for the
the high ph
so by doing the scoop and dump process
we are able to
decrease our bulk densities increase our
organic matter
improve our soil structure increase our
water holding capacity
increase our aggregate stability improve
our soil microorganism community
and as well as create
more soil volume for for plants to be
able to explore
so here are a few shots of locations
where
we have used this technique and what
some of the gardens look like today
okay so i'm going to take the last a
little bit of time in this talk
to talk about some of the the
practicalities of
implementing this technique and the
first thing i want to show
is just a cost estimate of some
of the parameters that we're looking at
if we want to actually implement this
the the main costs associated with the
scoop and dump technique are your
compost as well as getting
a backhoe machine in to use so
depending on where you work if you work
in a place that already has access
if you make your own compost this cost
can be eliminated
or decreased as well as if you work in a
place where you have access to the
referred to a machine then the rental
costs that i've projected here
are not going to be an issue as i
mentioned before
it is possible to do this technique also
just
with shovels and by hand but a very
important aspect of the scoop and dump
technique
is is doing the physical fracturing of
the soil
it's not simply adding compost
the compost with the mixing is what
creates this
soil mixture and that's where we find
the benefits here
so i just want to make that point kind
of clear so
estimates on an 100 square foot bed
depending if you want to go depending on
your depth of
compost you want to apply if we're
talking about about the six inch range
which would be
fairly typical that would take about
just under two yards of compost
um and i estimated
in this measurement for the bobcat mini
excavator to be rented for a three hour
period
so we're talking about for a hundred
square foot bed is about 212
dollars scale that up to 1 000 square
foot bed which would be a fairly large
size bed
but certainly something if you're
planning a large installation
is for the six inch depth you're looking
somewhere around
725 dollars again it's important to
think about
uh where your compost is coming from if
what kind of source and how expensive
you can
that is going to be as well as the
machine use
but the one kind of point when we do
think about costs that i want to
bring up is just the idea
that we know that this technique
improves your soils over the long
term so you have to think about it more
in terms of
making an initial investment and then
over time
it's going to continue to pay off and
this is going to be particularly
pronounced if you're working in a
at a site that has had plant failure in
the past
by using this technique you're going to
hopefully be able to decrease on plant
failure
and therefore be saving money by not
having to replace those plants
nearly so often or hopefully not at all
and when it does come to selecting
plants to be putting in this bed
what we talk about in the urban
horticultural institute is always
selecting your plants based on your
site's limitation
and the urban horticult the urban
horticultural institute
has a number of different resources
available to help you figure out what
your site limitations are
and i'm just going to talk about them
kind of briefly here
so the first one we oftentimes consider
is to be cold hardiness
and most people are familiar with this
there's very good maps by the usda which
will tell you what zone you're in
and you always want to select your plant
first on in
based on zones so you know that it can
thrive on the
minimum temperature that you find in
your area
the next thing you consider is soil ph
and you're either going to have
you're going to have very you could have
very acidic soils
or very basic soils
and based on this again there's not much
we can do instead of select the right
plants that are going to
like that environment you can make
changes to soil ph that is
a possibility but oftentimes when we
think about in the urban setting
a cost that we do not tend to
incur because we don't actually tend to
change the soil's ph
it's easier to select a plant that can
deal with a kind of ph range or
in instead of going out and buying a lot
of amendments
light is the next indicator you're going
to have full sun which is
six hours or more in a given day
part shade which is going to be less
than that or full shade which is maybe
at most an hour of light in the day
the next area that we consider is to be
moisture which
is how much water is going to be at your
site so whether you have a site that
frequently floods
or frequently drains very fast and
actually stays very kind of dry
or if you're lucky enough to have
something that can kind of do both it
will
infiltrate water quickly but also hold
on to it
and as well as salt exposure and this is
something that we see particularly in a
lot of institutional type settings or
as well as on in transportation type
areas we're either getting salt exposure
from de-icing salts
or salt soils if you're in a part of the
country where
salinity is an issue in your soils
so we have a great resource available to
us
here at cornell we've got the woody
plant database
and what's great about the woody plant
database is you can go on to it
and figure out your site's limitations
plug those into our database and what
will happen is it will generate a list
of plants that are
appropriate for your environment
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
some of these assessments most of these
assessments of site limitation you can
do on your own
in a pretty straightforward kind of a
way and then you can use the woody plant
database to find plants that are going
to be
that are going to work for your
landscape
another resource available to people is
the site assessment checklist
and this uh comes from a book written by
the urban horticultural institute
which is recommended urban trees site
assessment
and tree selection for stress tolerance
so similar to the um
the database i was referring to a moment
ago and in this book
it's free and available on our website
online
but you can go through and they also
have a checklist where you can actually
go through each of your specific
limitations
and kind of check them off for a given
site
and then you can use that information to
then select plants after that
so as i mentioned before i've talked a
lot about the concept of soil health
what it is cornell has
a soil health testing lab so you can
actually
take soils and collect them and send
them into the lab and they can go
through a battery of tests
many of the ones i've talked about today
as well as
some other ones that i haven't focused
on as much and
for 85 dollars you can get a full
package where you get a really good
picture of what's going on
and i would say that this is a great
tool to use specifically
if you're doing a new management
technique on a piece of
on a piece of land and you kind of want
to see how your soils respond over
change over time
most soil testing it's always you always
want to do it when
before you're about to establish a new
site or if you're trying to understand
what's going on with a site specifically
if you're having
issues with with some of your plant
failure
or you're just trying to get a better
sense but it's also something that's
good to test over time
and that's what's really convenient
about the soil health test is that
it is responsive to management so if you
test one year
maybe two or three years down the line
you can test again and you can kind of
see how your soils have changed in
response to your management
uh there's a few add-ons if you're
concerned about heavy metals you can add
that onto the test
as well as soluble salts if that is
another concern for you as well
i would say if you don't want to go and
get
the full package for 85 you can also
send in and get what we call
a cart or specific tests done and i
would say if you're going to get a
minimum set of tests you should get
your texture looked at you should get
your organic matter looked at and you
should get your ph looked at
since these are all at least texture and
ph is something that you're probably not
going to be addressing
in changing on your site but will be
very informative
when you want to select plants for that
landscape
and then there's actually a whole bunch
of tests that you can do
on your own the do-it-yourself
assessments
and these are bulk density resistance
with a penetrometer
ph and then some of the site limitations
which i was discussing before
so texture light hardiness
salt exposure and moisture
so i'm going to just talk about some
doing some of these assessments yourself
the first i'm going to talk about is
specifically bulk density
bulk density as i've mentioned many
times is a measurement of
weight by volume if you're doing
a lot of soil testing it's wise to
invest in a soil
a can that you can use specifically to
test these
and it's a pretty straightforward
process if you don't want to buy one of
these you can also cut off two ends
of a soup can anything that you know
the specific size on or you can measure
and figure out the specific side
so what i want to show here briefly
touch on is the actual technique of
taking a bulk density measurement
and it's a pretty straightforward
process what you really need for it
is just a few things you need a wood
block you need a can
and you need a hammer as well as an oven
at home
and a cookie sheet and
this is a specific soil core that soil
stamp
people who are doing a lot of soil
sampling will use
if you don't want to purchase one of
these you're only doing maybe one or two
sites
you can also use something like a soup
can
as well you of course want to be careful
not to cut yourself but anything that
you can measure
the height and as well as the diameter
so you can calculate the volume
afterwards
bulk density is a specific measurement
of weight
by volume and therefore tells us our
compaction in our soil
so the technique is pretty pretty
straightforward we'll go
out to a site and we'll if it's turfed
what we'll do is we'll slice the turf
layer off and then we'll come in and
we'll take our core
put on the soil on the top of the soil
come in with our block and our hammer
and hammer it down
until you your soil level just
just reaches the top of the can at this
point you can smooth it out
and then you're going to come in with a
trowel trowel underneath it
it's good to get a cap but if you don't
want to get a cap you can use anything
that's flat
so cap one side of it flip it over
smooth the soil out as well and
this way you know now you have a known
amount of volume of soil
within this canister you can take this
soil
push it into a bag you take that bag of
soil
bring it home put on a put on a cookie
sheet put it in your oven
at 200 degrees for two or three hours
until all the salt until all the
moisture has evaporated out you can take
that soil out
allow it to dry and then weigh it
and since you know the volume of your
cylinder and the weight
you can then figure out your weight by
volume
and therefore you know your bulk density
uh the next kind of do yourself
assessment
is looking at soil resistance with a
penetrometer
these are available from cornell
directly you can
borrow them for a week at a time where
we'll ship them out to you
and you can get one of these
penetrometers if you wanted to look at
compaction across a lot of sites
and the the main thing with these is
that it's it's best to do it
um kind of after it's rained a short
period afterwards
but if as long as you assess all your
soils within a short time frame so the
soils don't dry out too much
you can get a pretty good relative
indicator to each other
but like i mentioned before they're
pretty straightforward in how they work
you've got a pressure gauge on one side
and this is graduated so there's
actually measurements
on this pole specifically
and as you push this down into the soil
what you're going to see on the top
is increased pressure the only
caveat other than moisture on this is
that there's two different
tips you can get there's a 3 4 inch tip
and a half inch tip
and you only need to use the bigger one
if you're working in very sandy soils
next is texture texture by feel
this is different than the way that the
if you sent soils into the lab that they
would
look at texture but there's a number of
resources available
that are just flow charts where you can
collect a small amount of your soil with
a little bit of water
and you can you can go through the
practice
of of assessing those soils and getting
a texture simply by feel
this is a common uh field assessment
technique that a lot of
farmers or land care practitioners or
and certainly soil scientists will will
develop so they can understand what the
textures
of their soil without going through the
full test so
at the bottom of this pa slide there's
also a link available
where you can find a texture by feel but
there are a few out there
the next one that you can look at is ph
ph is another indicator that is very
easy to assess
on your own at cornell we sell
ph testing kits they come in two
different ranges they come in a wide
range
as well as a standard range your
standard range being
from ph of 5 to 7.2
and you're in your wider range being
from
4 to point six uh and then we also offer
one that's in the low range which is
from
four to six point two ph so you can buy
a single one of these boxes for 12.50
it will last you a very long time it's a
pretty straightforward process of
taking a small amount of soil placing it
into these
into these dishes and then using the
different reagents
and a color metric scheme to be able to
tell
what your range is in so particularly if
you want to do a lot of
sites across your campus you could buy
one of these kits for 12.50
and you'll be able to do a lot of
assessments you compare this to the cost
of doing the ph test on its own if you
send it to the lab
which is twelve dollars for one test so
if you think you're gonna be doing
uh even testing more than one site it's
in it's worth it to invest within
the ph kit and you can also follow the
links on this powerpoint
to get more information there's a few
extra slides here that are just at the
end of the presentation
the first thing i want to share with
people is a general workflow of
what you might want to be thinking about
if you want to implement the scoop and
dump technique
and the first consideration you want to
think about is whether you have a site
that is just
top soil is present and it's just
compacted or impacted
you can follow this workflow and
determine the best
how much compost to apply and at what
stage
you can also use this technique if you
are on a construction site where you
strip the topsoil and have it stockpiled
somewhere else
you can use the scoop and dump technique
on that lower subsoil level
to improve your soil quality when you
reapply
your topsoil at the end and a lot of
work
by susan day has focused specifically on
this technique of removing topsoil and
putting it back on
along with the scoop and dump technique
or the profile
rehabilitation as she calls it
this last slide is a slide of just some
basic measurements for understanding
bulk density
it's just gives you the equation for
finding the volume of a cylinder
which is a very simple equation and one
you need to
know to figure out the specific bulk
density
of soil and last but not least
there is some additional resources and
links here to the urban horticultural
institute
if you'd like to reach out to me or any
of my colleagues for further questions
or conversations as well as the cornell
soil health
lab if you'd like to get the test done
or any specific components of the test
and the cornell nutrient analysis lab if
you would like to do
comprehensive testing of either composts
or soils
for nutrients and with that i want to
thank you all for joining me today
and please feel free to reach out in the
future if you have questions
or would like to learn more about the
scuba dump technique
and rehabilitation of urban soils thank
you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu